"Два роки тому Україна стала притулком для понад 5000 білорусів,
які знайшли у собі сили виступити проти диктатури та брехні.
Сьогодні білоруська влада скеровує свою армію вбивати тих, хто підтримав вас у складний час," -
з такими словами українці звертаються до білорусів на щойно створеному українськими волонтерами сайті "Застанься дома".
На сайті білорусам надають інформацію про втрати обох сторін і наслідки вторгнення Росії в Україну,
а також закликають матерів, дружин та доньок Білорусі не відпускати рідних чоловіків на війну,
натомість виходити на вулиці і чинити опір самопроголошеному президенту Олександру Лукашенку.
Російські військові від самого початку війни використовують Білорусь як плацдарм для нападу на Україну.
Ці супутникові знімки колон військової техніки, що прямує до Києва,
були зроблені 28 лютого в Гомельській області Білорусі - Мозирі, Хільчисі, Тешкові.
Як стверджує агентство "Рейтер", колона розтягнулася на десятки кілометрів.
Знову ж таки до білоруського Мозиря, як стверджує телеграм-канал "Білі халати",
надходять сотні поранених російських солдатів.
Більшість військових з легкими пораненнями.
Та й сам Лукашенко ще у перші дні підтвердив, що росіяни запускали ракети по Україні з території Білорусі.
Так, були пуски з території Білорусі…
За даними Пентагона, в перший тиждень 70 з майже пів тисячі ракет по українським цілям запустили з Білорусі.
Тож міжнародна критика не оминула й ролі Білорусі у вторгненні РФ в Україну.
Путін зруйнував мир у Європі.
Союзники засуджують невиправдане та жорстоке вторгнення в Україну.
Російський напад абсолютно неприйнятний, і його підтримує Білорусь.
Білорусь також порушила свої зобов'язання щодо Статуту ООН та міжнародного права.
Дозволяючи Росії використовувати свою територію для вторгнення та нападу на Україну,
Білорусь допомагає незаконній агресивній війні Росії.
Що я скажу загалом про Білорусь, так це те, що влада та Лукашенко дозволили президенту Путіну
поглумитися над незалежністю Білорусі, над її уявним суверенітетом.
Це відбувається вже протягом деякого часу, коли російські війська спочатку заполонили Білорусь,
розташувалися на території, яка має бути суверенною білоруською територією,
щоб зробити навмисний, невиправданий, неспровокований напад і вторгнення в третю країну.
Весь цей час режим у Мінську продовжує жорстоко придушувати демократичні устремління народу Білорусі.
Країна, як я вже казав, дедалі більше підпорядковується Росії, демонструючи готовність президента
діяти проти інтересів власного народу, щоб заручитися прихильністю Москви та залишитися при владі.
Водночас у соцмережах наприкінці лютого з'явилися повідомлення, що у Білорусі
формуються цілі підрозділи для участі у війні в Україні на боці Росії.
Дехто з молодих білорусів, як повідомляють кореспонденти DW в Білорусі,
вже навіть отримав повістки для прибуття в мобілізаційні пункти.
Непокояться і ті, чиї сини нині служать в білоруській армії.
Білоруси здебільшого проти участі їхньої країни у війні Росії.
Згідно з опитуванням Chatham House, за відправку солдатів строкової служби в Україну висловилися лише 12% респондентів.
57% впевнені, що участь Білорусі в конфлікті обернеться катастрофою для країни.
Насправді ЄС та США вже розширили наявні санкції проти Білорусі
за сприяння режимом Лукашенка вторгненню російських військ в Україну.
Лідерка білоруської опозиції Світлана Тихановська, яка перебуває в екзилі,
тим часом оголосила антивоєнну мобілізацію білорусів.
Вона також звернулася до українського народу та президента.
Ми захоплюємося вами, дорогі українці та пане президенте!
Ваші дії - взірець єдності керівництва держави і всієї нації.
Ми ж, білоруси, проти режиму, який вже здав частину суверенітету нашої країни,
щоб стати частиною агресії проти вашої країни.
За словами Тихановської, учасники антивоєнного руху в Білорусі намагаються перешкоджати участі Білорусі у війні проти України.
Зокрема його учасники виводять з ладу залізничні шляхи,
якими перевозять військову техніку до кордону з Україною, протидіють пропаганді.
Білоруси за кордоном збираються до вас на фронт,
допомагають біженцям і займаються поставками екіпіровки й медикаментів.
Білоруські матері переконують військових не йти на війну.
І вони починають досягати успіху.
Білоруси формують національний корпус з добровольців і військових,
які відмовилися виконувати злочинні накази Лукашенка.
і готові боронити незалежність України і Білорусі.
Таких білорусів дедалі більше, і вони - ваші союзники. Тепер і назавжди.
Про готовність брати участь у спротиві агресії російської армії повідомив, зокрема,
колишній мінський ресторатор та відомий критик Лукашенка Вадим Прокоп'єв.
Нині він перебуває під Києвом і готовий воювати за Україну і за Білорусь.
Білоруські солдати й офіцери, не робіть дурниць, не здобрюйте українську землю!
Переходьте на наш бік! На цьому боці також білоруси.
А відомий білоруський співак Сергій Міхалок, засновник гурту "Ляпіс Трубецькой",
також звернувся до білоруських військових.
Куди ви лізете? Схаменіться, поки не пізно!
Вашими руками два тирани, два довбо... Путін і Лукашенко роблять свої брудні темні чорні справи.
Солідарність із українцями висловлюють і прості білоруси.
Так, скрипаль зіграв гімн України у мінському переході.
28 лютого на антивоєнній акції у Мінську, за даними правозахисного центру "Вясна", затримали 61 особу.